I'm home ah good morning John it's
January 5th and I'm sitting in my
basement back home surrounded by all the
things I love I love orange juice
I love Mental Floss Magazine and
Benjamin Franklin everything is reversed
when I look at it on the computer I
thought he was over here I love these
old collages that were on my wall in
college that I still have taped together
because I think maybe someday I'm gonna
put them back up on a wall someday I
love that right there see it there
that's a map of the realm of Narnia yeah
it's a map of the realm Barnea hold on I
have to go upstairs and get something
movie magic lies of a mission what did I
get
we don't actually have Strawberry Hill
here I didn't know that I'd never looked
for it until today alas Sutter home
white zinfandel we'll have to do it's
going to be kind of embarrassing if I
having in this stuff from the fridge
when friends come over but it's your
challenge and you did stick several
pieces of toilet paper in your mouth and
discuss the political situation in Nepal
I'm glad that I wasn't stuck with the
political situation in Nepal challenge
because I don't actually know anything
about Nepal except maybe that there's
rocks and that's only really because
there are rocks everywhere a commenter
suggested that I drink a glass of
Strawberry Hill wine and then say eat
five sheets of toilet paper while
discussing the political situation in
Nepal usually fast without vomiting I'm
going to do that there's only one way
that I'm going to be able to do that
and that's by getting corndogs eating
corndogs is the only way I can chug an
alcoholic beverage without puking I
don't know why I think maybe my
stomach's just like oh that corn dog is
so good I can't let go of it I have to
hold onto the corn dog I don't care how
much alcohol you pour in me just don't
let go of the corn dog I really like
corn dogs it's not strawberry hill but
it only costs three dollars and
sixty-five cents to Brotherhood
eight five sheets of toilet paper while
discussing the political situation in
Nepal hmm
that really wasn't all that hard what's
all the fuss about II five sheets of
toilet paper while discussing the
political situation and live palm